moi je voulais revenir sur cette
histoire de consentement qui est demandé
et cetera ça a été fait pour donner
confiance aux gens or si vous écoutez si
vous allez sur les pages anti-vaccins
cetera
ça leur donne pas plus confiance que si
on avait quelques obligatoire parce que
pour eux si on demande le consentement
c'est forcément quelque part derrière
c'est dangereux et qu' il va y avoir des
effets secondaires terrible et que c'est
pour ça qu'on demande à signer avant
pour se dégager de toute responsabilité
en cas de pépin donc quelle que soit la
manière dont on va prendre les choses
d'un côté ou de l'autre
il y aura toujours un loup quelque part
tour ces gens là
[Musique]